[Music]
Chile's former Central Railroad Station
influenced by French architect Gustav a
fell of Eiffel Tower Fame is not the
usual venue for a classical musical
concert
it's the dress rehearsal and everyone is
nervous especially members of the choir
who like Ignacio sepuldada have been
practicing for six months
a friend told me that non-professional
singers were being auditioned for a
choir at first I was terrified that the
choir director trains you and gives you
confidence to sing even difficult pieces
he's part of a Citizens choir who along
with professional musicians and students
are donating their time and talent for
what will be a massive free concert
before more than 5 000 people
it's the brainchild of Orchestra
director Alejandra urutia who wants to
bring classical music closer to all
people not just an elite we want to
bring to the to the world the community
to to our country this message of
Brotherhood
this message that we can all do
wonderful things together
in spite of our differences
you are hearing the Carmina Burana
cantata by Carl orff it's about life as
a Wheel of Fortune one that goes up or
down without any warning and that's a
concept that's very opportunity
particularly over the last three years
the next day the cultural center is
filled to the brim in downtown Santiago
as the concert begins
this is the third Grand concert for
Brotherhood held in Chile
[Applause]
ment is a symbol of unity in times of
civil Strife war and pandemics
it's being broadcast around the world
free of charge
same as experiencing this life
everyone who plays they have feelings of
about what they're playing and and when
you're alive in a live concert you can
feel these emotions and you can also
feel the emotions of the people sitting
next to you
[Music]
when the concert ends urutia invites the
public to sing the first movement
[Music]
classical music experience that the
organizers hope to spread well beyond
Chile's borders
see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago